hello I'm the Nostalgia guy remembered
so you don't have to Happy Thanksgiving
okay we're doing Christmas now because
Thanksgiving is just the stepchild that
nobody wants to pay attention to even
though they're family don't worry
Thanksgiving one day your fairy got to
come and make you so popular that we'll
start putting out Thanksgiving
decorations in September the of course
we'll have to move Halloween decorations
to August because we already have
September - guys I think those up
because said we only have until the end
of October to get ready for that is
everyone looking for calendars upside
down why do we never celebrate the
appropriate holiday with the appropriate
amount of time now don't get me wrong I
know it's all subjective there's no
official rulebook for any of this in
fact the dates attached to May these
holidays are usually several days if not
several weeks off from when they
originally were supposed to be
celebrated but you know what I'm talking
about Christmas decorations being put
out the same time as Halloween
Thanksgiving being forgotten between two
other holidays more holidays being made
up just so companies can sell more
products something weird is going on and
we need to figure out this is a good
thing or a bad thing okay it's a bad
thing but let me explain why for years
most people celebrate the classic
holidays around the same time span a few
weeks usually a month preparing for the
special occasion you can tell this by
how many people associate the month with
a holiday that the erase of time for
Valentine's Day March is a time for st.
Patrick's Day April's the time for
Easter etc but somewhere down the line
we didn't just enjoy these holidays we
got super obsessed with it
if holidays were people we'd be fucking
stalker they're being restraining orders
out on all of us so is it the marketing
teams that say the earlier we get this
out the more products we can sell and
profit from well yeah but there's a
little bit more to it than that every
holiday is gonna have a different
reception ranging from slide to extreme
it's unlikely you'll celebrate Christmas
with the same amount excitement you'll
have for Presidents Day
though I'm sure there's a few out there
but the major ones I mentioned before
have gone to simple nice moments with
family to extreme
access we're more excited for these
holidays now than we've ever been before
companies wouldn't force these holidays
on us so early if we weren't buying them
up so early so the buyers and the
sellers are feeding into each other so
naturally that raises the question why
have we become so obsessed okay I know I
shouldn't talk with my slide fixation
over a certain holiday save it but even
I know that some of these holidays are
getting so big that they're overlapping
over totally fine ones why is
Thanksgiving becoming more and more
overlooked especially with more and more
store staying open and thousands of
people waiting in line instead of eating
a family meal you could argue as
consumerism gone mad and in some cases
it has anything that can be exploited
for profit will but we feed into it not
just because we like materialism though
again it does play a big part but
because I don't know if you've noticed
we're kind of on a being nostalgic
movies merchandise songs we've become
focused on reliving the happiest parts
of our childhood it went from
underground hipster talked to big big
bugs
we love to relive those happy innocent
times over and over and over is this a
bad thing it can be if you glorify the
wrong areas but you could always look at
as we're trying to figure out what made
us so happy in the past and use it more
in our everyday lives
remember when Christmas and Halloween
were just seen as kid stuff well now
adults love it reminds us of that
special feeling we got as children and
now we can pass it on to our children
but on top of that by trying to reclaim
those carefree times many more people
are becoming carefree in real life but
those 50 years ago didn't really dress
up for Halloween but now plenty of
adults do and with great technique now
it does Azmi we've gotten so uptight
that we're craving our carefree ways or
have our carefree ways made us less
uptight it's probably something everyone
can answer a little differently but it
does explain why we have such a hard-on
for the holidays that gave us the most
memorable childhood memories
the downside is we are connecting it too
much to the holidays and not to our
normal state of being we want Halloween
and Christmas to come early because we
like what we do and who we are around
those
Lyons so it just makes sense to
celebrate earlier and earlier I guess
it's not bad but how about this idea try
doing the things you want to do and
being the person you want to be any day
you don't need a date to be nice people
go donate to charity or find a friend in
need you don't need an excuse to make
awesome costumes or projects help
there's a ton of conventions every year
dedicated to people who celebrate their
personal likes and they do so by
building incredible things there's
people that go on the streets make
videos do all sorts of things with
incredible creations because they just
like it why wait for a holiday they can
do this shit right now we don't need a
certain time to come earlier to feel
better just do the same thing every
other day the holidays are supposed to
be reminders of what's wonderful in the
world
Christmas reminds us of how important it
is to care Valentine's Day reminds us of
how important it is to love Thanksgiving
reminds us of how important it is to be
thankful and Halloween reminds us of how
important it is to stir things up a bit
we go overboard with celebrating them
because we want to show how much we
treasure these values which is fine but
we're not bound to do them only during
the designated shopping days hell if I'm
in a Down mood I'll sometimes put on a
Christmas CD even if it's long after
Christmas I don't because those songs
are about peace and harmony and those
are worth enjoying even after the
holiday is over their values that still
work even if it's not the 25th of
December so are we going to keep
celebrating holidays at strange times
probably but it's not about when it
starts it's how long you keep it going
hell even more holidays are getting
recognition celebrating even newer
values but as always the idea is not to
help create a holiday but rather a
better life doing things that you should
be trying to do every day except maybe
st. Patrick's Day you'll be an alcoholic
but you get the idea let the holidays be
a reminder to do great things not
permission instead of extending their
message another month why not practice
it the whole year who knows the more you
praise how much you value the great
things in life the more you might
actually start to value it all the time
I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy remember it
so you don't have to
hello I'm that's the first time I've
gotten that wrong
heydo Walker here doing the charity
shout out uh this is one that a lie you
have probably heard of but it can always
get more and more attention and more and
more help and that is st. Jude's
Children's Hospital this is a hospital
that specializes with children who have
cancer and we all know cancer is a
horrible it's one of the worst things
you can go through but it's so much
worse what happens to children and this
is a place where families can go and
they don't charge them a thing you look
at all the videos and testimonials and
all the parents saying that really
nothing is asked of them nothing is
charged at all because of the donations
because of people being so supportive
and so giving because so many people
know that no child should ever have to
go through this so they do everything
they can not only to give these children
the proper care but also try to find a
cure this is a research facility as well
that tries endlessly to try and find out
new things in how to treat the disease
and how to make the children feel better
and how to cope with it better
everything you can imagine this is one
of the most popular charities you can
find out there and it's popular for a
reason because they really are so
wonderful and put so much effort and so
much dedication into what they do this
is a place where children can feel
welcome they can feel warm they can feel
loved they can feel like this is a place
that's safe for children had to go
through so much they deserve nothing but
the best and this is definitely an
organization that gives it and puts
their all into it
there's updates all the time on their
website and information on how you can
help hearing any of the stories and
watching any of the footage you can see
that this place knows what they're doing
and that they do it well so definitely
click on the link check it out and see
why this hospital is known all over the
world
you